bonsoir avec ses poulains merci d'être
soit avec nous rentrée des classes donc
jean-michel blanquer requis des tailles
implants de thèses parfois un petit peu
difficile à suivre
oui on voit bien que c'est la rentrée
qui est préparé avec amateurisme avec
fierté et dans l'improvisation la plus
totale un peu comme d'habitude bon on a
l'habitude depuis un an j'ai envie de
dire puisqu'il a été annoncé les tests
salivaires sur les élèves pour voir
s'ils étaient porteurs de différents
variant ou pas sauf que qui va faire les
tests salivaires les syndicats de
professeurs s'en sont émus les médecins
et infirmiers scolaires également alors
jean michel blanquer ra a repris la
parole un ces derniers jours pour dire
bien il y aura un recrutement de 1700
médiateur qui sont des étudiants
pharmaciens médecins en santé ou ou non
qui vont faire ces gestes pour tester
les élèves
l'idée c'est de passer de dix mille
tests par semaine actuellement alors il
s'agit de tests salivaires beaucoup
moins intrusif 1 que les tests pcr et de
monter jusqu'à 300 mille tests par
semaine à la mi mars
c'est vraiment une organisation qui pose
encore beaucoup de questions sur à la
fois le recrutement de ces médiateurs
est-ce que ça fait partie du dispositif
un jeune une solution alors jean michel
blanquer radics oui ces emplois seront
payés on ne sait pas combien tout ça est
vraiment inventé au jour le jour pour
répondre à cette crise sanitaire puisque
comme vous l'avez dit le quoi qu'il en
coûte pour jean michel blanquer r c'est
de ne surtout pas fermer les écoles
c'est l'exception française et il y
tient pour lui la continuité pédagogique
eps est le plus important
et puis il ya bien sûr les merci aux
médecins scolaires aux professeurs qui
ont reçu une prime de 150 euros pour
s'équiper en informatique c'est très peu
a comparé aux prix actuellement des
biens informatiques et numériques
et puis la prime d'attractivité de 100
euros par mois qui commencera à être
versés pour les professeurs les plus
jeunes à partir du mois de mai donc on
voit bien que l'objectif fondamental de
jean michel blanquer est de garder les
écoles ouvertes pour ce faire il va
falloir faire beaucoup de tests
on attend de voir si le pari va être
tenu dans les semaines qui viennent
oui pour jean michel blanquer donc le
quoi qu'il en coûte ces deux
fermer les écoles sauf en dernier
recours oui c'est exactement ça et alors
le ce quoi qu'il en coûte
il est étrange parce que la france
finalement est à contretemps des voisins
européens qui avaient choisi eux de
fermer les écoles au mois de janvier en
début d'année pour éviter justement la
propagation des variants anglais
brésiliens et autres qui se commençait à
venir partout sur le territoire européen
c'est le choix est très différent de la
france de dire nous devons rester
ouverts et c'est en dernier recours que
nous fermerons pour éviter une
catastrophe éducative il s'agit de
suivre les recommandations de l'exécutif
qui a choisi une approche
territorialisée localiser avec
déconfinement le week-end on l'a vu sur
le littoral avec ce couvre-feu à 18
heures qui est censé selon jérôme
salomon porté ses fruits être mais pas
un modèle pour d'autres partenaires
européens qui regarde la france avec
envie et pourtant jean michel blanquer
redit il faut voir effectivement la
relation entre avantages et
inconvénients de fermeture des classes
alors c'est la doctrine bien sûr de dire
nous ne fermerons des classes en france
seulement s'il y a trois cas de variant
angles est avérée et lorsqu'il ya un cas
de variants sud africain où un cas de
variants brésiliens qui sont des
variants beaucoup plus contagieux
le problème en france c'est que on va
peut-être faire des tests salivaires
mais malheureusement on ne fait pas
assez de séquençage c'est ce qui permet
de savoir en fait en temps réel quels
sont les variants qui circulent sur le
territoire nous on fait en fait des
petits drop pour savoir à quel moment
tous les quinze jours
quels sont les variants aujourd'hui
c'est le variés anglais qui est le plus
disséminé qui est en train de prendre le
dessus sur les autres mais on voit bien
que si on garde les écoles ouvertes
évidemment que ça risque de circuler à
vive allure
on est loin du compte pour jean michel
blanquer pourtant ils lisent et les
élèves et les enfants respectent
davantage les gestes barrière à l'école
qu'en vacances par exemple où il dit que
les contaminations seraient plus
nombreuses ça reste à voir
là encore les études sont
contradictoires et puisqu'on parle
d'école alexis quid de la vaccination
des professeurs et des enseignants est
bien là encore pas de stratégie
particulière de l'exécutif sauf de dire
que les professeurs de plus de 50 ans
avec des comorbidités ou
vont pouvoir se faire vacciner
immédiatement pour les autres eh bien
ils devront attendre que les classes
d'âge soit ouverte à la vaccination il
n'y a pas de stratégie pour choisir des
publics particuliers prioritaires que
sont les professeurs les métiers de
contact les soignants là encore il
faudra simplement attendre que les doses
arrive puisque on manque toujours deux
doses et aussi que la logistique arrive
à suivre
aujourd'hui par exemple astrazeneca
n'est pas distribué de nombreuses doses
du vaccin astrazeneca dorment dans les
frigos en france
et puis comme ce vaccin et bien
finalement on arrive pas à l'administrer
à la vitesse qui avait été annoncé on
commence à parler des traitements contre
le coronavirus c'était ce que disait
obligé vers ans lors de sa conférence de
presse jeudi dernier la france a décidé
d'utiliser ces traitements d'anticorps
monoclonaux produits par le laboratoire
eli lilly laboratoire américain
le médicament s'appelle le pam la nive
imams assez imprononçable et les
résultats de ce médicament sont
contestées là encore il ya eu un peu la
précipitation du gouvernement français
c'est un traitement très cher de 1000 à
2000 euros la dose mais la france a
commandé parce que l'allemagne en avait
commandé environ deux cent mille doses
et puis il faut savoir que au sein du
comité de direction dit lily en france
la responsable notamment de l'accès au
marché des nouveaux produits via est une
proche du premier cercle du parti la
république en marge du parti des macros
est ce là encore un conflit d'intérêts
en perspective l'avenir nous le dira et
puis il y a les déclarations du chef de
l'état hier à stains devant des jeunes
qui a dit il faut encore tenir ensemble
pour environ quatre à six semaines
alors on ne sait pas d'où il tient sa
jean castex a expliqué il a remis une
couche aujourd'hui un oui vous savez
avec le climat et la vaccination qui
continue peut-être que on va en sortir
d'ici quelques semaines mais les
semaines devant nous pour être les plus
difficiles est clairement aujourd'hui
les français n'ont pas de cap
on reste devant un horizon bouché sans
date sans savoir comment cette crise de
coronavirus va être gérée dans les
semaines qui viennent et la suite
aucune date de réouverture des
restaurants des lieux de culture des
cinémas tout est en impesanteur
finalement on est suspendu à au conseil
de défense
chaque semaine il y en a 1 demain matin
c'est peut-être le conseil de défense de
la dernière chance pour éviter art
confinement parce que
émana mâcon a choisi de ne pas re
confiné si jamais ça devait arriver ce
serait un camouflet assez sévère pour le
chef de l'état
donc si jamais on confine ce sera
localement et avec un autre vocabulaire
sans doute pour ne pas contredire est
vrai le mag
merci alexis poulin et peut-être des
débuts de réponse à demain pour la
énième conférence
voilà exactement merci à l'exil poulain
merci d'avoir été avec nous